Hey okay the point did y'all's get in  oh yes yes ma'am was that they call it  Carolina style Carolina style no son we  do Memphis style on this here family Oh  life is hard oh wow that is uh that is  really sweet  yeah I'll be in in a second so when will  the ribs be ready about six hours  well she was just cute as a button but  you know I heard it with some drugs  involved he's going deeper Craig's up  ran off into the sea captain um I heard  one time she puked in at church  hey Phenom Oh  oh so you follow our battle football uh  yeah totally  roll tide roll tide  take a left right down where that live  oak is and all the way down the road and  you can see Walmart on the right you got  hotel is gonna be on the left great  happy guys bring it on in  I'm in love with your daughter